hi my name is Eddie whoo and today I'm
going to walk you through proof by
mathematical induction many of us play
with dominoes when we were younger
patiently setting up everything in a row
has a tremendous payoff when we get to
start of a huge chain reaction with a
single tap mathematical induction is
exactly the same once we establish all
the pieces of the argument they knock
each other over in a brilliant
demonstration of mathematical logic and
just like a row of dominoes all it takes
is a tap to make induction work
mathematical induction has three
essential parts we test we assume and
finally we prove octo you might I mean
with an example this is the induction
question from last year's maths
extension one HSC exam it's asking us to
prove that this statement is true for N
equals one and it was two N equals three
and so on until infinity it might seem
at first that this would take an
infinite amount of time to prove but the
genius of mathematical reduction just
requires a few lines of working I'll
show you how first we need to test that
the statements true for its first given
value from the question we can see that
N equals 1 we want to show that
substituting N equals 1 into the
equation satisfies it and makes a true
statement remember to pay careful
attention to this first value which is
sometimes called the base case it's
usually N equals 1 but on occasion it
may start N equals 2 or some other value
don't just guess
read the question substituting the value
into each side independently is the best
way to go first we'll go to the
left-hand side this is the sum of all
fractions in this form up until n on n
plus 1 factorial for N equals 1 that
means 1 on 2 factorial is both the first
term and also the last term at this
stage we need to remember what the
factorial function is we first met this
in the topic of binomial theorem and it
means taking a positive integer and
multiplying by all the positive integers
less than that so 3 factorial is 3 times
2 times 1
in our case 2 factorial is just 2 times
1 so the left-hand side is simply equal
to
a huff now we can try the right-hand
side and going through the substitution
shows that we get exactly the same
result that means our test succeeded and
we can move on to the next stage assume
what we're doing here is taking a
statement and assuming that is true for
a particular value of M in other words
we've shown it's true for N equals 1 now
we're going to assume it's true for N
equals K where K is just the name we're
giving to our particular value time
dates of our Domino's from before this
is like saying if we select a particular
Domino we assume it can be pushed hard
enough to make it fall over now we're
ready to make the magic happen
we've tested for N equals 1 we've
assumed that it's true for N equals K
and now it's time to prove that the
state that's true for M equals k plus 1
in other words if one would fall over
then the next one will fall too this is
the statement we're trying to prove
which start stood k plus 1 into both
sides of the equation and even though
we'd written this down we don't actually
know whether it's true or not we need to
show using careful algebra that one side
is equal to the other we should start
with one side and manipulate it to can
show that it's identical to the other
side I'm going to begin with the left
now something worth noticing is that the
original statement has n terms on the
left 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 up to M the
assumption has K terms on the left and
the statement are now working with has k
plus 1 statements on the left I can't
write all of them out but you can see
I've included the second last and the
last term's because when I do that you
can see that this line has something in
it I can use everything in this line up
until K on K plus 1 factorial is
included in my assumption that means I
can use the assumption also called the
inductive hypothesis and make a
substitution
remembering that I assume that these two
are equal to each other
I replace one with the other now all
that remains is to work with what's left
behind to show that it's equal to the
right hand side I can use my knowledge
of the factorial function to get a
common denominator
two fractions which then allows me to
combine them into one from there it's
very straightforward to show the result
I wanted and my proof step is complete
now we know this the statement is true
for one value that it must be true for
the next value as well that's like
knowing that if any one of these
dominoes fall then the next one is also
guaranteed to fall but since we showed
it's true for the first value that means
it's true for the second value and the
third all the way to infinity it's like
pushing over the first honor and the
rest of them will come along for a ride
so remember mathematical induction is as
easy as giving Domino's a tap test
assume proof